the key thing that marginal analysis
helps us solve is what is called the
water diamond paradox
so you will die without water we all
need water and yet water is dirt cheap
whereas diamonds are uh extremely
superfluous nobody needs them
um nobody's gonna live or die because
they have a diamond and yet they're
extremely expensive so why is it that as
human beings we pay
maybe say a dollar a liter
for water whereas we pay thousands of
dollars for a few grams of diamonds
why is this the case do we value water
less than diamond
the answer is no but at the margin
where we are right now you live in a
place where water is very abundant
because cities are only built in places
where water is abundant
and um
you're only making a choice about the
next unit of water and so water is
extremely abundant and
you're choosing about whether to spend
the next
unit of money on water the valuation
that you give to water given that you
have a lot of water at home
and then you live in a place that has
abundant water
is pretty low to the marginal unit
but it's very high for water overall so
if i asked you
how much would you spend for
water in general you know how much would
you
pay for water for all of your life it
would be a lot higher than diamonds if i
told you you can only have water or
diamonds for the rest of your life you
choose water obviously
but you nobody's ever had to make that
choice you only make your choices at the
margin
so at the margin where we are modern
civilization we have an abundance of
water that's why we have civilization
and diamonds are very rare and scarce
and um
people are only buying you know you buy
your first diamond when you're going to
get married and you give it to your wife
and that's it's going to be the first
few grams of diamond that she's ever
going to giving my wife water
smart move you should definitely give
her bitcoin instead of diamonds i tell
my wife i occasionally remind her what
uh what we how many bitcoin we could
have had if i bought her bitcoin with
the price of the diamond what's the
downside of by the way diamonds for from
the analysis of like gold and so on ah
that's a great question
um
arguably diamonds are scam
[Laughter]
because they became popular as a thing
in uh marriage
after gold was banned after gold
ownership was banned in the us in the
1930s and in many places around the
world so before that you'd give gold and
the reason you'd give gold in a dowry in
uh wedding
is because you know it wasn't just that
it's pretty and shiny it's because it's
money and so um you know if you die and
your wife can take the gold and she can
live off of it um it's a demonstration
that you're giving her something
valuable
and that's because nobody can make a lot
more gold that has the high stock to
flow ratio but then they banned gold
ownership or they allowed people to only
own very tiny quantities of gold and
that's when the diamond industry stepped
in and marketed diamonds as
the thing that you need to give but the
problem with it is of course that
diamonds aren't
like gold they're not very hard to
make more of and the reason we have
scarcity in diamonds is really
artificial there's a there's effectively
a monopoly of diamond producers they
restrict the supply
and um it's a pretty dirty business and
the way that they do it is you know all
the um all the talk about
blood diamonds is a way for them to
ensure their monopoly so
if you're part of the monopoly of
diamond producers then doesn't matter
how many people get killed producing
your diamonds if you're out of the
monopoly then human rights organizations
descend on you
and call for shutting you down for
selling blood diamonds and they're also
restricting the production of artificial
dimes this is the other thing you can
make artificial diamond you can't make
artificial gold
so they restrict the production of
artificial diamond and they try and um
insist that you know you shouldn't take
artificial diamonds but
they're indistinguishable from real
diamonds so it's an artificial scarcity
and i think there's going to come a
point at some point that this monopoly
is going to break and a lot of people
are going to be left with uh
essentially uh
highly devalued uh jewelry i'm going to
take this segment of the podcast when
i'm getting married i'm going to send it
and then instead you're getting
uh water or bitcoin yes water and
bitcoin is all you need
you